des géants pharmaceutiques menacé d'être
poursuivi en justice par berlin en cause
des retards de livraison qui
ralentissent la campagne de vaccination
dans tout le pays
les laboratoires sont accusés de ne pas
respecter leurs engagements
un conflit qui pourrait entraîner une
riposte de l'état fédéral comme le
précise le ministre de l'économie
peter altmaier dans une interview pour
le journal allemand die welt
s'il s'avère que des entreprises n'ont
pas respecté leurs obligations nous
devrons décider de conséquences
judiciaires
parmi les laboratoires pointé du doigt
astrazeneca le laboratoire britannique a
annoncé des retards conséquents et les
tensions montent autour du troisième
sérum validé par l'union européenne ce
samedi le ministre allemand de la santé
jentsch panne a annoncé que son
gouvernement souhaitait suivre les
conseils de leurs experts
ces derniers doutent de l'efficacité du
vaccin britannique sur les personnes de
plus de 65 ans et ce malgré le feu vert
de bruxelles
astrazeneca à une restriction d'âge que
les deux autres n'ont pas de 18 à 64 ans
selon la recommandation de la commission
permanente de vaccination qui est
dirigée par le professeur mertens et
bien sûr nous devons maintenant
l'appliquer dans lordonnance sur la
vaccination
astrazeneca n'est pourtant pas le seul
groupe pharmaceutique dans le
collimateur des pays européens l'italie
a déjà fait par le 20 janvier dernier de
son intention d'attaquer le laboratoire
américain pfizer
si les retards de livraisons venaient à
perdurer une aubaine pour d'autres
vaccins déjà en circulation ailleurs
dans le monde
ce dimanche 6 ème span a affirmé dans
une interview pour le journal allemand
frankfurter allgemeine zeitung que
d'autres options étaient sur la table
quel que soit le pays dans lequel un
vaccin est fabriqué s'ils sont sûrs et
efficaces ils peuvent aider à faire face
à la pandémie
ce lundi
union nationale doit se tenir à berlin
les autorités allemandes et les
fabricants de vaccins seront amenés à
discuter de ces retards de livraison
afin de trouver une solution
une pression qui vient s'ajouter à celle
exercée par l'union européenne depuis la
fin de la semaine dernière